for those of you who don't know this is
Roxy My Husky she's the OG rock star
that helped me launch my social media
career he has more than 2 million
followers on Instagram talk about a fan
club
[Music]
today I want to share a very important
story of something that happened with
Roxy it's a terrible situation as you
can tell she's now a tripod a
three-legged dog and she's doing well
but this situation could have been
avoided and I want to arm you with
information that you should know when
you have to make a choice when your pet
gets sick relax you come
[Applause]
that's it good dog good dog you good dog
so to set up the story
um Roxy now lives with my dad so he
takes care of her vet stuff takes her in
for checkups and Roxy had sort of a bump
growing on her
um right arm and this bump was there for
several years it may have grown slightly
over the course of those years but this
bump never bothered her so I wasn't too
concerned about it but my dad said you
know what I'm going to point it out to
the vet on the upcoming visit which I
thought was a very good idea so when
they went to uh go get this bump checked
out in an overall physical they said you
know for 12 years old this dog is doing
very well in good health running all the
time she's so fit she's so active she
looks like an eight-year-old dog but
they said we want to take a sample of
the bump on her leg and send it for
cytology which means that under a
microscope they look at and see what
cells are there to decide is this a
cancerous lump non-cancerous slump Etc
so after my dad went and he gave my
phone number for the vet to call back
and then when the vet ended up calling
me back they said that you know
unfortunately the cytology came back and
it looks like this is a cancerous bump
they called it a sarcoma which means
that it's a soft tissue cancer and they
recommended bringing the dog back in for
a consultation with the surgeon
I know how surgery is difficult on
humans and I can only imagine how
difficult it is on dogs who need
activity in order to stay fit in order
to stay mentally well especially dogs
like Roxy she's so active she's a husky
she has so much energy in her so I I
told my dad a list of questions that I
wanted him to ask the surgeon those
questions are questions that you should
always ask before going in for a
procedure a is this type of cancer that
Roxy has dangerous in that is it likely
to spread is it likely to cause problems
elsewhere in her body what's the
five-year survival rate what impact will
this have on her life as a 12 year old
dog is it worth for a 12 year old husky
to go for a surgery on her leg to remove
a tumor that so far has yet to cause a
problem and I thought my dad being a
physician would be well armed to ask
these questions and I trusted him to do
so I actually don't talk to him the
following day when he actually went for
the visit and the next day he sends me a
picture of Roxy wearing a cast healing
up in the sun in the backyard and I
thought oh wow she must be doing so much
better because she's healing and he goes
she's doing awesome post-op the doctor
told me that it wouldn't be that big of
a procedure and that they could likely
do this you know in and out one day's
time and they thought it was beneficial
I was a little bit skeptical but you
know seeing the fact that she was
recovering was very promising to me
so over the next few
days things started to change
she had to go in for multiple wound
checks to get her wound examined because
the area where she had the tumor she had
a very thick bandage on my dad couldn't
check it himself there was sutures in
place Staples in place and they needed
to constantly check this so she was on
antibiotics they were doing these checks
I noticed that the bandage was on really
tight but you know I'm looking at
pictures and I'm trusting my dad and all
this stuff
and then like a week goes by and my dad
calls me while I'm working in the
hospital and says mike like I need you
to come home after the hospital and look
at Roxy's like I don't think it's good
and I'm like but wait like I'm not a
surgeon a I'm not a vet B
um if you think it's bad then that means
probably we should go get it checked out
at the vet and he was like no I have an
appointment with them like in two days
I'm gonna go then that's when the
surgeon is there because he's on
vacation you know some complicated
things like okay of course I'll come by
so when I came by
I'm looking at Roxy's foot it was now
unwrapped
and this is a graphic photo but I'm
gonna show it
um
her foot was dead her paw was dead like
there was no blood flow it was a cold
foot it smelled gangrenous which means
it was becoming infected I was like Dad
like this is terrible like she's gonna
lose her foot like there's no like this
foot has clearly not had circulation for
a long period of time and for me what I
wasn't sure of was this an issue of the
bandage being very tight or was this
more of an issue surgically that when
they removed the tumor they also took
out extra tissue and possibly the blood
vessels that go down to her foot
and my dad like never clarified this
with the surgeon Roxy leave it so I was
very like upset about that and wondering
the whole time a should a Roxy have
gotten the surgery B did the surgeon
make a mistake C was the bandage on too
tight and honestly it's really hard to
know so that when my dad actually went
in there they basically said yeah look
we think we should amputate and my dad
let me speak to the surgeon and I asked
the surgeon very frankly like look is
this a mess up did we take out too much
you know um
tissue that the blood vessel came out
along with it because if you take out
the arteries and the blood vessels that
are higher in the leg they essentially
feed circulation to the bottom of the
Paw it would never heal the bottom of
the Paw then or was it that the bandage
was on too tight and the rehab process
or is she an older dog and this is a
normal complication that happens time to
time and he basically said all of the
above
and
while I appreciate the honesty because
he said look we have to take out a lot
of tissue the tumor was larger than we
expected
I think like if I was working with a
human surgeon I think that we would have
thought about those risks that if we
open up or are potentially getting ready
to open up a person's
um body and then we see that we can
cause more damage than actually benefit
by
doing a biopsy or removing a tumor we
actually don't do it so I asked the
surgeon like what was the dog's staging
of the cancer and it was a stage one
sarcoma and not to say that this isn't
serious it's just that at 12 years old
Roxy's life expectancy is maybe another
two years she's getting in that range
it's sad to say Obviously but you know
we're really hurting her Quality of Life
by putting her under the stress that
surgery plus the risk of um
this thing's going wrong like right now
so poor Roxy in recovering from the
surgery was barely able to walk was very
sick during that time
and then now we're saying we have to
amputate her entire leg and not just the
entire leg the scapula as well because
apparently in dogs this is the way to do
it I asked about a prosthetic but he
said that that would require a second
operation as well and she would have to
learn to use it and an older dog and
being a Husky which is a breed that
tends to be more picky with pain he said
that she might not even adapt well to it
he recommended just taking off the
entire leg
and uh kind of told me some new
information that I didn't know about
dogs that they tend to handle
amputations better than humans because
they don't have the psychological
traumatic component of this where they
don't miss having the fourth leg that
you know she's like okay I have three
legs this is what I do and that's who I
am and that's the dog I am and I move
forward can I get a high five
or is that messed up task oh good girl
good girl here you get a bonus and
because of that they seem to rebound
quite well and I will say out of this
whole process that's probably been the
most accurate part of it that Roxy has
recovered quite well thank God she had a
mean scar you can't really see it now
um but it's healed up quite well we took
out the Staples a few weeks ago she's
now going for longer walks with my dad
when I come home she's wagging her tail
she's still shedding like a monster as
you can tell from all of my clothes
she's still super sweet she's happy
obviously slightly lower energy because
she fatigues and now I know she has
higher risks of getting arthritis in her
legs because she's unbalanced she has to
put more stress on each one of the
joints yeah it's sad it's sad watching
you know your dog gets sick with
whatever condition it is so all in all
this goes to say you know when you bring
your dog to the vet make sure you're
armed with good information make sure
you ask how hard questions of both not
only the General Vet but the surgeon
make sure they give you accurate risk
assessments because it's very easy to
say oh we'll just take this out easy
peasy no problem but then like your dog
can lose a limb and it could be quite
frustrating because it feels like you
didn't get all the information but know
that pets are sadly not Immortal and you
want to think about their quality of
life
just as importantly as you do the length
of their life
so hopefully Roxy continues to be a
little rock star that she is she loves
her treats and I'm really glad that you
know this terrible situation kind of had
not the worst ending